hi good evening my name is Tim Ramsey
and I'm the manager for the George
Washington University class we really
appreciate you coming this evening we
feel we have an exciting program seem
like you're welcome you to the GW club
which is a faculty alumni staff and
Friends of university club founded in
nineteen ninety nine clubhouse was
originally known as the Lawson Whitney
house circa 1857 to 1858 typical the
mid-nineteenth century few of these
types of semi-detached homes remain in
this in Washington today so making the
loss of Whitney house important to the
illustration of Washington's early
growth Kathleen filing shouts and
Uruguay embassy last inhabited these
homes the club is also a setting for a
portion of the university's permanent
grant collection collection documents of
life and times of ulysses s grant the
18th president of the United States
donated to the University by grants
grandson grant was a trustee for the
university grants dining room table and
chairs are well as well as a poster
chairs can be found in the club in the
grant parlor on the first floor is
important oil of grant by George Peter
Alexander Haley 1877 several other
pieces of art from the University
collection hang throughout the club on
behalf of the Board of Governors we hope
you enjoy your evening and welcome you
back again soon it's my pleasure to
present to you lon go far dr. George
Carlo and Martin Marty Schramm's agent
thank you
I don't really belong up here on the
Midwife of this book but let me say on
behalf of my clients of a few things
that they might be too immodest to say
about this sadly important book I say
sad because it is unfortunate that a
book like this had to be written but
important because the need was there and
they've done a really splendid job of
bringing public information important
information to the public that we all
need to know and there are some very
important lessons about both science and
public policy that they will talk about
for those of you who some of you I now
have been invited by the bride and some
by the groom I can tell you by way of
introduction George Carlo is that great
combination of being both the doctor and
a lawyer a kind of Jewish Mothers dream
boy
has avoided the pitfalls of both
profession and apply themselves to
public health problems in ways that we
all have to be very grateful for Marty
SRAM is an old friend of mine and a
former newspaper editor and now one of
the my think most savvy columnist
writing about public affairs so I was
happy to be the Midwife of this book I
wish it had been unnecessary I wish they
were both doing something else but I'm
glad the need having been there that
they did this book I remember when
George first came to my office to talk
about his work he told me that that this
cellphone phenomenon is the biggest
selling product in the history of the
world I had a interesting lesson in that
this past weekend I went to the Ericsson
to watch some terrific tennis and at the
most intense and quiet moments all of a
sudden you would hear around the stadium
BBB BBB gonna be booed every everybody
went was listening to that nobody had
their vibrator on everybody was
listening to a cell phone it is it is
such a ubiquitous problem that they
write about it seems that whether it's
Ralph Nader talking about automobiles or
Eugene yg and talking about tobacco or
Carlo and SRAM talking about cell phones
we we seem to wish to deny the truths
that commerce won't let us face up to
but this important book does face up to
it and it's a great public service that
they've done it so without more I know
this this this evening is one of you all
want to get back and see the West Wing
so I turn it over now to the authors to
tell you a little bit about the book and
I know they'll receive any of your
questions great of mainly I have spent
my comment Washington covering
presidents and so writing a book about
cell phones is unusual perhaps one of
the nicest presidents I covered with
Jerry Ford and I'm reminded of his
campaign effort in 1976 when he was
whistle stopping through Illinois and he
was on the back of a train stopping at
every town all those towns look
like and poor jerry ford he kept getting
the name of the town wrong because he
kept getting mixed up and we left in
joliet and went to Lincoln Illinois and
he said it's great to be here in Joliet
Lincoln and then we went to Springfield
and he said it's great to be here in
Joliet Lincoln and Springfield well God
loves you God love Jerry Ford he then
tried to recover he said ladies and
gentlemen I'm great to be here so let's
have no mistake about it you're great to
be here c-span is great to be here Ron
you're great to be here and the George
you have to be here and soda why we're
glad why did I write a book about cell
phones because Ron introduced me to
George Carlo and the first thing I did
George is I really started to try to
check you out so I really want to write
a book about cell phones and especially
co-author a book with with anyone and
who is this guy George Karl oh well I
found out that he's a scientist and that
he'd been following the science hired by
the cell phone industry to do the study
that proved there were no problems with
cell phones and isn't what I found out
anyway was as long as he found there
were no problems he had no problems with
the industry then when he began to
follow the science and his team found
that there were problems which he'll
talk about at that point he began to
have problems and I found that a lot of
my journalistic colleagues found it very
easy to pick up derogatory smear
information about George Carlo the
industry was playing hardball that made
me want to do the book and so we've done
this book cell phones i think is
unfortunately an important book and we
we saw several things George will talk
about the science it turned out to be
the kind of book that I really do report
and write and have in the past many
times it's a book about the power game
in Washington about industry lobbyists
who had game plans for how to spin the
Congress and the federal regulators
and it's a book about federal watch dogs
who didn't bark and there's a lot to
tell and a lot to read and at least we
tried to write it like a novel like a
detective story but it's about science
George thanks Marty well when I first
went to talk to Ron Goldfarb about doing
this book I explained to him the problem
that we had done we've done work over a
period of seven years that we had
received 28 million dollars from the
cell phone industry and that we had
conducted more than 50 studies and we
found some problems and that the
industry was not happy with the findings
and that I had been in a position where
I don't think the the full story was
able to be told because everything that
i said was being spun in many different
ways and that the public really wasn't
in a position to hear the information
that they needed to hear so ron being a
literary agent said well you know you
need to write a book and he asked me he
said well can you write so well sure I
can write I'm a scientist you know I
have over a hundred publications in
journals medical journal scientific
journals written a couple of chapters
and books I fact I already have a book
on cell phones she said well send it
over so I sent it over called me the
next day and he said well said the
object is to keep people awake said so
we're going to have to get you some help
and that's how I met Marty shrimp and I
have to say that while he was spending
three weeks checking me out I was
spending three weeks checking him out
and it was a very interesting thing that
every place I turned and asked the
question about Marty SRAM I got the same
answer great guy great writer great
journalist very difficult to work with
it's all true so Marty and I said about
in april of last year to begin writing
this book and having never written a
book like this before i thought well we
can pound this thing out in a couple of
months not recognizing that he usually
takes a couple of years to write a book
like this and it it turned out that
Marty and I worked about 20 hours a day
for somewhere around six months and we
became alter egos we ate at each others
house we argued with each other both of
us quit at least twice and in the end we
had which what I think is a very very
important book the the bottom line on
this is is as follows cell phones in the
early 1990s took the world by storm they
had never been tested for safety before
they were put on to the market and they
were not tested for good reason because
there was no scientific reason to
believe that cell phones could cause
health problems and that was because the
conventional wisdom with regard to
radiofrequency radiation was that if you
didn't have enough energy to cause
heating of biological tissue like a
microwave oven or if you didn't have
enough energy to break DNA then there
was no reason to believe that there
could be adverse health effects coming
from cellular phones so that when I took
this job in 1993 with the idea that the
cell phone industry would put what
ultimately became 28 million dollars
into this my view was that it was
important to do this work it was
important to do the research but I never
thought we were going to find anything
and at the beginning
I thought that the major problem we were
going to have was that we had received
all this money from the industry and
that people were going to criticize our
work for having been nothing more than
what the industry wanted and what the
industry bought so because of that we
made sure that we had several layers of
independent scientific peer review we
brought in the Harvard School of Public
Health to put in place an independent
peer review boards look over everything
we did we also asked the federal
government to become involved and the
Food and Drug Administration impaneled
an interagency working group that
included scientists from the National
Cancer Institute from the Food and Drug
Administration from the Environmental
Protection Agency and all the other
federal agencies that had a stake in the
whole question of cellphone health
effects the reason we did this was to
make sure that all the work would be
done above board to make sure that there
would be peer review so that and I have
to admit this that I felt that this was
the only way that we could protect
ourselves from being criticized later
finding no health problems and not have
it be as though the industry simply
bought the results well everything was
fine until nineteen ninety-five when we
found that the pulsing from digital
funds interfered with implanted cardiac
pacemakers and we put together a large
clinical study that included the Mayo
Clinic the University of Oklahoma and
Boston University and we studied more
than a thousand patients and we found
very clearly that the pulsing signal
from a digital phone indeed interfered
with implanted cardiac pacemakers some
of that interference was inhibition
meaning it could stop the pacemaker from
doing its work if you're a pacemaker
dependent person that's a very serious
problem that means you have no heartbeat
so we went public with that finding we
publish the finding in the New England
Journal of Medicine we made
recommendations to pacemaker wearers to
the public into doctors about how to
avoid that problem the solution is a
distance if you keep the phone more than
six or seven inches away from the
pacemaker there is not the problem of
interference the industry however did
not like that when we put the program in
place we said we were going to be
independent I don't think they believed
us so we independently went out with
those recommendations with the Food and
Drug Administration behind us the
industry promptly stopped the funding
for the program in over a period of nine
months we had no financial support for
this very important public health
program as Marty and I detail in the
book during that time there were a
number of discussions i would say
between me and members of the industry
many of those discussions were trying to
figure out alternatives to the program
that we had put in place many of those
discussions involved things like George
want you come and work with us we'll
take care you but you got to be quiet
after nine months we finally reached an
agreement where the industry was going
to put another 13 million dollars into
the program and we were going to go
forward finishing the fundamentally
important studies of biological effects
now a little bit about the science and I
don't want to go on too long and I want
to take some of your questions but when
we began the program in 1993 being a
public health guy it seems
straightforward to me that we needed to
identify if there were any health risks
and if there were health risks we needed
to identify ways of mitigating
or eliminating those health risks pretty
straightforward find the problem and
find the solution when we began the work
in 1993 the first shocker that I had was
that there were no tools available to do
experiments to do studies that would
allow us to extrapolate or generalize
from the laboratory to people so we had
to develop new scientific tools new
laboratory methods new ways of examining
what happens to people who use cellular
phones we had to bring in some of the
world's top experts in the book we talk
about the fellow who invented the
stealth technology for the stealth
bomber came and helped us figure out how
to expose rats in tubes to the same type
of radiation that comes from a cellular
phone so that by the time we finish
those tools and began the long term
studies we were now in 1997 in the
beginning of 1998 the first round of
studies that came in in 1998 did not
show any problems they were studies that
looked at whether or not the radio waves
could break DNA and the answer was that
there wasn't enough energy from those
radio waves to break DNA so everything
looked good up through December of 1998
but at the end of nineteen ninety eight
right around Christmas I got a series of
results in from our laboratory in North
Carolina that showed that human blood
exposed to radio waves from the cell
phone had something in them called micro
nuclei now micronuclei are little pieces
of DNA that have been broken that do not
go back together properly but they're
functioning well enough to form a
membrane around them and when you have
micronuclei that means you have a
functioning defective part of that cell
that can clone itself and multiply and
when that happens you have the
development of a tumor now this type of
finding is definite genetic damage the
level of radiation exposure that caused
that genetic damage was the exact level
that we have in people using cell phones
that type of genetic damage is serious
had that finding occurred prior to
phones being put into the market for
example as part of pre market testing
which wasn't done for phones but which
is done for pharmaceuticals for example
pharmaceutical drugs the phone would
never have made it to the market that
finding would be enough to keep a
pharmaceutical drug from going into the
market after the Chernobyl explosion in
the 1980s they monitored the people who
lived around that nuclear power plant
for the presence of micronuclei in their
blood and if they found micronuclei
those people were worked up as the
highest risk for developing cancer so
this finding in Christmas of 1998 of
micronuclei was very serious and when I
got those results I sent them back to
the lab in North Carolina I had an
interesting discussion with the
scientists who had closed down for
Christmas and I said guys you're going
to have to do this again because this is
a very serious serious finding so they
worked all through Christmas and they
came back in January with another set of
results showing the same thing so now we
had two sets of laboratory experiments
looking at every type of cellular phone
technology showing genetic damage at the
same time we had a series of studies
going on
looking at people who use cellular
phones and one of those studies was a
study of brain cancer among people using
cellular phones now one of the things
that we found out was that the radiation
from the cellular phone antenna
penetrates only a couple of inches from
the antenna so that when you put the
phone next to your head the radiation is
penetrating a couple of inches into your
brain now from a scientific point of
view what that means is that only brain
tissue on the outside of the head can
possibly be affected by the radiation
from the cell phone antenna in in this
study that we had under way in five
hospitals in northeastern United States
we had included all of the brain cancers
even the brain cancers that were more
than two inches away from the antenna
and the doctors came back with the
finding with all of the brain cancer
saying there was no increase in the risk
of brain cancer associated with cell
phone use but we looked at that and we
said you know what let's just see what
happens if you only look at the tumors
that around the outside of the head
because we don't see any way that the
radiation can penetrate more than a
couple of inches when they did that they
found that the risk of developing tumors
on the outside of the brain was almost
three times greater in people who use a
cell phone compared to people who didn't
use a cell phone it was a statistically
significant increase in the risk of
neural epithelial tumors we had another
study that was looking at the risk of
acoustic neuroma which is a benign tumor
of the nerve that controls hearing in
people who had reported using a cell
phone for six years or more there was a
fifty percent increase in the risk of
acoustic neuroma we then looked back at
other studies that had been done and
what we found was that
the radiation from a cell phone caused a
breakdown in something called the
blood-brain barrier this was the fourth
finding now brain tissue is very highly
specialized it does nothing but think
it's not able to ward off infection
fight off any type of environmental
insult it only thinks that's why we have
two protections for brain tissue that
have evolved one of them is a thick
skull so it protects the brain from
trauma the other one is something called
the blood-brain barrier the blood-brain
barrier is a filtering system in the
blood vessels that are in the head and
what that filtering system does is it
keeps the dangerous chemicals that are
circulating in your blood from reaching
sensitive brain tissue what we found was
that the radiation from the cell phone
broke down the blood-brain barrier
opened up the blood-brain barrier so it
made it possible for those dangerous
chemicals that are circulating to reach
the sensitive brain tissue so now we're
in February of 1999 we have four
findings that are very very troubling
they're clear red flags of warning clear
red flags saying something is going on
here now in 1993 there were 15 million
people using cell phones in 1999 there
were a hundred million people using cell
phones so that now we had red flags of
danger that could impact a hundred
million people so I went to the industry
and I went to their trade meeting and I
met with the board of directors of all
of the major companies and I told them
what we found and I recommended to them
that they needed to do more work but
that they needed to let the public know
what was known and what was not known
and also to let the public know that
there are things that they can do to
protect themselves if they're concerned
one of the things is to use a headset
because if the radiation from the
antenna is only penetrating a couple of
inches and you keep the antenna away
from you you use a headset like this
well then the radiation is too far away
from you so you don't have to worry
about the industry heard my
recommendations they said they were
going to properly follow up but it isn't
what they did they began with a public
relations campaign that tried to lead
consumers to the conclusion that there
were no health risks from cellular
phones they began with advertisements
and pamphlets in all the stores around
the country quoting old scientific
information about no heating no breakage
of DNA and it culminated in a series of
interviews that I did with the media
where one one in particular you know we
had talked a little bit about our
findings they had been made public and I
was of course I would talk to whoever in
the media wanted to hear about this and
I was doing this interview they got from
the New York Times the New York Times is
pretty big and prior to this I'd done
about 50 interviews and not really shy
and I sort of pick up on what's going on
in an interview and after about 20
minutes I looked at this guy and I said
said what I said what what's what's
going on because he was looking at me
like I was crazy and he told me he said
well he said I met with ctia yesterday
that's the Trinity
that's the trade association and he said
that they said you were not they said
you were unstable and that your findings
couldn't be believed now at that point I
decided that you know I was going to
have to take a different tack and I did
agree to do a series of interviews with
ABC's 2020 and CBS is 60 minutes and
decided that the only way that the
public was really going to hear about
this was for us to talk about it and in
the fall of nineteen ninety nine twenty
twenty did a full hour piece on the
scientific work that we had done and the
findings prior to that 2020 show the
industry tried to bring a lawsuit to
stop that show from going forward on 20
20 20 20 s lawyers they got a lot of
lawyers those guys they checked it out
and they decided to go forward they
decided to go forward in the spring of
two thousand twenty twenty did another
piece public broadcasting has done a
number of reports on this so so the the
general word was beginning to percolate
out but I still didn't feel that it was
being portrayed in a fair and accurate
and balanced way and that's when we
decided to do the book you know one
other thing and then I'll I'll stop and
take your questions since we came out
with the book in january of this year
there have been three epidemiological
studies that have been talked about in
the general media now one of the
epidemiological studies was done by the
National Cancer Institute another one
was done by the University of essen
germany and another one was done by a
group of scientists hired by the cell
phone industry in Denmark to look at the
risk of brain cancer and other cancers
associated with cell phone use the
National Cancer Institute study did not
find an increase in the risk of tumors
mainly because they did not have the
kinds of tumors that occur on the
outside of the head in the study the
investigators talked about that in the
publication that appeared in the new
england journal of medicine they talked
about they said you know if we're
concerned about rare tumors on the
outside of the head never the radiation
from the antenna comes from we can't
deal with that in this study we don't
have any of those two they also pointed
out that the radiation only goes about
two inches inside the head and most of
their tumors were not even in that area
so they really did lay it out clearly
they laid it out clearly but the New
York Times carried a headline saying all
clear for cell phones because the
industry had very deftly put together a
package a public-relations package that
was so thick that the reporter from the
New York Times told me I got to go with
that story cuz I don't have time to read
it I have a deadline at five o'clock
when the Danish study came out the same
kinds of headlines occurred because the
industry packaged that up now in between
that National Cancer Institute study in
the Danish study the University of essen
in Germany study came out this study
showed somewhere between a tripling and
a quadrupling somewhere between three
times and four times greater risk of
developing melanoma of the I a cancer of
the pigment of the eye in people who use
cell phones compared to people who do
not highly statistically significant
three hundred to four hundred percent
increase in the risk
there was no coverage of that finding
there was no coverage of that finding
there were no press releases so that
what's happening is that the public is
being misled now all told there have
been seven epidemiological studies of
people who use cellphones seven in the
world five of the seven studies show
increase in the risk of tumors we also
have finding showing genetic damage we
have finding showing leakage in the
blood-brain barrier now one final word
of caution we shouldn't be seeing
anything in those human studies it took
us a hundred years of people smoking
before we saw the first signs of lung
cancer risk in smokers a hundred years
for asbestos mesothelioma of the lung
took eighty years before we begin to see
the signs in people you know why because
we're the top of the food chain for a
reason our bodies are tough we know how
to fight environmental insults we know
how to fight disease cell phones have
been in widespread use for less than a
decade not even a whole generation so we
shouldn't be seeing anything we also
have a circumstance where children are
being marketed to with Disney characters
on phones where they have family plans
where you can buy one caught that one
cost you can have four phones on the
same number and not have to pay for all
of that their marketing the children
nobody knows nobody knows the impact of
somebody using a cell phone they're 9 10
12 years old using it for the rest of
their life but there is one thing by the
way that we do know
studies that are in our book and even
photographs you see the damage the
penetration of a cell phone in adult
head and it's about this much and in a
in a teenager's head about this much and
for a six-year-old it goes almost from
one end of the head to the other because
the skull is informed so that Disney
phone decal idea was really a bad idea
and George the only good news of the
cell phone industry they never said
anything about it but they pulled those
Disney characters off the market that's
right now we didn't rehearse this but
what he's talking about is actually in
the book this is the cross section of a
head of a skull ok this is the radiation
penetration in an adult that little
thing there is the ear this is the
penetration into the brain in an adult
this is the penetration and the
ten-year-old child this is the
penetration in a five-year-old child now
already in England and in France there
have been government steps taken to warn
against children using cell phones in
the United States nothing has been done
in the United States right now the cell
phone industry is unregulated with
regard to health and safety it is an
unregulated industry so consumers are
really on their own terms of safety as
we go to questions we should we should
also add that the there is nothing that
we've said that the federal regulators
don't know the FDA has all of this
information they've run days of seminars
studying the documentation and the
studies that George Carlo and his team
did they know all about this at the very
least they could be going on television
and telling you what they know at the
very least
questions at what point is the radiation
and that's the problem the really
radiation from is the most severe here's
here's what happens when the phone call
is first made during dialing and ringing
there are a whole bunch of connections
that have to be made between the antenna
and the base station that carries the
signal so the maximum amount of power
the maximum amount of radiation coming
from that power occurs during dialing
and ringing at the beginning of the
phone call as the phone call goes on the
amount of power drops off as does the
amount of radiation however the most
important determinant of how much
radiation comes from that antenna is not
how long you're on the phone but it's
where you are when you make that phone
call with relationship to the base
station the further away the base
station is the harder that phone has to
work it has to put out more power
therefore the radiation amount is higher
that's why sometimes when you look at
your phone it has the four bars in the
left-hand side of the display when it
has four bars showing that means the
phone is pretty well cruising it's not
working too hard but when you have two
bars or one bar the phone is working
very very hard which means it's the
maximum amount of radiation coming from
that phone now with that being the case
we don't know whether one ten-minute
phone call is better or worse than ten
one minute phone calls we can't say at
this point that's why the only
recommendation that we make in the book
is for people to keep the antenna away
from their body it's the only
science-based recommendation that can be
made at this point
how about the two of you do you use the
tough own self telephones used cell
phone i use it and i use it with a
headset so does George so do i well one
other one of the things that people need
to know is a lot of times people say oh
I don't need to pull the antenna out I
can hear it just fine like this wrong as
George told me one of our first meetings
the radiation comes not out of the tip
of it but out of the middle right there
two inches around so if you've got it
down here like this oh the whole phone
is become an antenna and you're really a
much greater risk put it out you're
better off if you have one of those self
cellphone where the antenna goes off to
the side you're still better off if
you're wearing a headset using a headset
you're ahead of the game yes hold the
phone out from your pocket by your chest
we that affect your heart or your chest
rainy or means they wouldn't I would
assume they would need protection there
would you be better off putting it
simply button by the liver yeah there's
there's no good way that but actually I
as a courtesy to george i turn my cell
phone off so I it's not on but truth be
told when it is on it's also there or
sometimes I wear it at my waist neither
way is good but as soon as it rings I
try to take it off immediately and hold
it away there's no good way to have your
cell phone on your body and and keep it
detached from you unless you're going to
carry it at the end of a stick and
that's rather inconvenient loading
though so
if you had it in your coat pocket by
your number as the science guy that make
any difference or no not really I mean
here's the here's the thing that the
first is is that by carrying the phone
in your breast pocket for example if you
have a pacemaker the phones on that's a
bad thing because when the phone rings
during dialing and ringing what do we
have the maximum amount of radiation and
most of the time pacemakers aren't
planted in the clavicular region anyway
they're right here so that that's not if
you have a pacemaker that's not a good
thing to do if you don't have a
pacemaker the radiation is not doesn't
really care whether it's brain tissue
liver tissue heart muscle or whatever it
penetrates two to three inches away from
the antenna when the phone is in dialing
and ringing now when the phone is on and
you're just carrying it around there's
really no radiation it only happens when
there is a connection between the phone
in a in a base station but the the
interesting thing about that is that
there are a number of companies now that
are developing shields that would be
able to be used you know on your waist
in your around the phone so that the
radiation arguably would not penetrate
now the the bad news and we point this
out in the book is that the Food and
Drug Administration here in the United
States and other regulatory agencies
around the world have not demanded that
these companies that have these products
that are supposed to be mitigating the
effects of radiation be tested to make
sure that they can meet their label
claims now why because the food and drug
administration has not been able to
admit here in the United States that
there's a problem with cell phones let
me tell you the extent to which they
have not been able to admit it
in august of last year they ran the
two-day seminar of the top scientists
from all of the world came to study the
findings of George Carlos team and
others the micronuclei findings if you
will and then two weeks later the head
of the agency that ran that's that that
seminar went on the Larry King show a
whole hour on CNN devoted to to the cell
phone issue and he was asked do you see
any problems he said we see no health
effects period if you take a look at his
quote and put it up against the quote
that Motorola was putting out and had
been putting out for years you'll see
they're identical I have a real problem
with that I think they should at least
tell us what they know what is in their
files what's in the National Cancer
Institute files where this is why George
says I'm hard to work with because I
said George when you talk about
micronuclei it's not enough go tell me
what I can tell people that will mean
something and we found a bunch of
reports in the National Cancer Institute
files that say that the cancer experts
say that micronuclei is quote a
diagnostic marker for high risk for
cancer and that's a real concern yes
mari is a student at media using
comedian is ignore this balkanization
why I think the media has not ignored
this book but they've certainly slided
it and part of the reason is because of
the studies that have come out the
epidemiological studies that George
talked about and this is very
interesting this is this is the real
failure of my profession these are
reporters who look at the studies and
they say no problem and that's what the
headlines say and so on what they don't
realize is that these were studies by
statistical people and not laboratory
scientists they studied tumors that
could not possibly be reached by a cell
phone and then concluded that the cell
phone didn't cause that problem and that
does not seem to be a very strong
assurance to me i'm not very reassured
by that yet we face a new danger
now and that danger is a danger of
flawed studies that lead to false
assurances and lead people to not take
the steps that we can all take to
protect ourselves wear a headset that's
that's a real concern yes other than the
the brain tumors and the pacemaker of
conditions what other there been any
other studies on on the results of the
medical or medical conditions as a
result of wearing it on your hip and
other than I the eye the eye finding is
very very serious this melanoma of the
eye is a very serious condition because
melanoma can be very fatal and if you
have that tumor in the in the coloring
of your eye it can very easily
metastasize become systemic so that is
not something that's trivial that that I
cancer finding is one that is very very
serious as far as I'm concerned they're
trivialize it I'm trying to get to
another point you know you're talking
about the concerns and we're all here to
hear about those and we're also
interested in finding out ways to
protect ourselves and you know wearing
these things on our hips which most of
us probably do you know you have have
there been any studies say with respect
to deliver or any other physiological
concerns with this in what since you're
a scientist and I'm not what compounds
or metals could be used to block the
radiation as it is from these antennas
and these phones from your body all of
those points are very important points
the answer is that no one is looking we
don't know about impacts on the liver
because no one is studying currently all
of the funding in the united states that
had been allocated to the study of cell
phones to stop the industry and the fda
have something called a crater a
cooperative research and development
agreement where they're going to begin
doing some more research and we point
this out in the book
where the kinds of things that you point
out are the things that should be done
impacts on children impacts on the liver
how about pregnant women you know we had
it we had an instance where we have this
little registry where people who have
health problems are able to call and
register confidentially the information
so that we can track see what happens
people use cell phones and this is the
true true instance woman was pregnant
and she was she had gained a whole lot
of weight during her pregnancy she had a
hard time getting up and walking so her
husband bought her cell phone in what
she was able to do is take the cell
phone and lay it on her stomach so that
when instead of having to walk across
the room to answer the phone she was
able to pick up the phone and talk so
and we had this in our registry she has
the baby the baby dies and it's a Down
syndrome baby now we have no idea
whether the cell phone had anything to
do with that but it's in our registry
and you know what there's no one looking
to see whether or not that kind of thing
is happening the only research that
they're doing in this crater is to
recheck our blood studies to see whether
or not they can come up with a finding
that shows no micronuclei and to recheck
the epidemiological studies that we did
on the neural epithelial tumors in
Britain and in France the governments of
funding studies in the United States the
industry funds the studies and the
government passes the assignments along
to scientists but the industry controls
the product so the short answer is that
the the work that should be done is not
being done the only work that's being
funded in the United States is work
that's being done to try to reverse the
findings of problems I'm happy
no scientists and you know you've
already stated that clothing won't block
this form of radiation or this form of
radiation what will well interesting you
mentioned clothing because Barney's in
New York this store they had a radiation
shield overcoat for sale for 900 bucks
we're supposed to block the radiation
damn thing weighed a hundred pounds you
know it was led and everything so so we
don't know exactly what to wear this is
going to move least it wasn't as bestest
yeah yes yes yeah I had a read article
depressed that when you use the
headphone in the cell phone as a concern
the radiation from the cell phone can go
up the wire to the headphone and still
come up next to your head comment on
that yes well there were there was a
study that was funded by a magazine in
England about 6-8 months ago called
which requests which which magazine and
they had gone into a laboratory and used
something sort of like a Geiger counter
to measure some kind of what radiation
might be coming from the wires in
headsets and based on that they came out
with a news story saying that the
headsets actually magnified the
radiation did they show you the
documentation there was no documentation
that was available and then when they
went back and redid it after they came
under tremendous amounts of criticism by
scientific groups around the world they
tempered their findings and said that
there are some headsets that may pick up
some radiation so the bottom line on
that is that there's no reason
scientifically right now to believe that
the headsets magnify the radiation or
our problem the difficulty is that the
news media pick that story up and with
the internet now it was all over the
world I every place I talk every day I
get that question all the time
and the the bottom line was that it is
not scientifically supportable yes I
know you poke just came out but what
reaction have you gotten from US
government officials either privately or
publicly in response to you all let me
talk about that just a little bit
because if you'll notice there is one
thing missing in our book that should be
there and that is a comment from the
food and drug administration since
they're the prime agency that's supposed
to be regulating this I asked them to
for interviews and they found out that I
was doing a book as a co-author with
George Carlo and somehow decided that
they wouldn't give us interviews what
they wanted instead they said was if I
will give them a list of questions that
i want to ask they will decide whether
or not they'll have an interview I
explained to the spokesperson for the
FDA that in 30 years in this town and
traveling throughout the world I've only
come across that one time really and it
wasn't really here in the United States
it was in the Soviet Union during the
Cold War when I asked to interview some
when I was told well they wanted to know
what I wanted to ask and then they
decide if they wanted to give me an
interview I said I don't I don't do that
it's a game and I'm not going to play
that game I interview every official
from presidents all the way on down to
the people who really know something and
in all cases I found that people are
very willing to just sit and answer your
questions unless they have a reason for
not they just wanted to know what was in
our book and now they do the interest
refinery actions
government official sentence come out
yes there are senators and
representatives who are especially
interested I don't have any private
reactions from the regulators yet my
guess is that on Capitol Hill they will
understand what the bottom line is and
they will do the right thing the General
Accounting Office is doing a study is
just finishing one and it will be very
interesting to see if they recommend
that the government agencies get
involved or continue to take no action
there's on to follow up two points on
that the first is that the FDA the Food
and Drug Administration is in a real Jam
right now and the reason is this is that
when cell phones were first put into the
market in the 1980s they gave them a
pass in terms of pre market testing did
not require any pre pre market testing
when the questions about brain cancer
were first raised in 1993 and there were
15 million people using cell phones the
FDA and the industry sort of made a deal
they said look we're probably not going
to find out anything anyway industry you
put in some money to do research FDA we
will not regulate until we have data
that was 15 million people well now we
have a hundred and ten million people
today the FDA is in the jam because if
they step forward and say there are
health risks from cell phones the next
question is well how did you let a
hundred and ten million people slip
through the cracks so that the FDA is
absolutely crippled now the other
reaction to the book that I think is
probably more telling than what comes
from the government is this is that you
know I use a headset and I'm on the
phone all the kind you know to the
credit of verizon they haven't canceled
my service or anything I still able to
pay in my thousand dollars a month and
they let me use the phone but I go
through these headsets like water I need
a new headset about every couple of
months so where I live over in
Alexandria in the Potomac yards there's
an AT&T store so I go in there all
I now of course the first time I went
into that store after 2020 because I
would imagine what happened was is that
everybody who worked in the industry had
to look at that tape so I went walking
in there and you would have thought that
well they recognized me and I had sort
of a chilly reception the next time I
went in you know I had sort of different
kind of reception and after the book
came out I went in and I needed a you
know headset and of course you know I
know right where they are and so now
what happens is this guy comes over he
says a man he says you're the guy huh
and I said I said what do you mean he
said you're the you're Carlo you're the
one who wrote the book and I said yeah
he said he said I've been reading the
book he said I haven't been able to buy
it he said but I going to barnes and
noble and i read it he doesn't really
want to own it then he hands me i bought
my thing and i had my little receipt and
he says you signed this for my wife so i
have a feeling that things are chilling
in the industry on this a little bit too
because look look all we're saying here
is that there are red flags of warning
we don't know what they mean long-term
but as a consumer you should have the
right to make your own choice about how
much risk you want to assume and it
really should be up to the government in
the industry to give you the information
you need to make an informed choice
about risk that's all we're saying yes
the without using the headset is the one
phone dangerous than the other like I
got this flip up and I feel like I have
the shield
say coconut dogs better than Bell games
than anything well as it turns out that
particular phone which is a start at
which has the antenna going out actually
changing now that plastic shield does
not do anything that does not do
anything radiation goes right through
that but the antenna that juts out a
little bit away from the head changes
the pattern changes where the radiation
hit doesn't eliminate it it just changes
where it hits the hits the head and the
antenna is two inches further away from
your head then it might have been
otherwise yes obviously money talks on
the hill so are you all planning on
having a coalition people lobbying for
your interest George is going to pay for
a whole bunch of lobbyists it's a good
idea George much you just fell out yeah
george'll do that you know um help some
money [ __ ] that way as opposed to being
fished only in the self-image well the
interesting thing the interesting thing
is this is that when we came out with
our findings in march of 1999 and
coincident with that you know all the
money stopped there still are bills that
the industry has not paid that are over
a year and a half old now and you know i
had the team of scientists some of them
are here people who worked with us and I
said you know we have to we have to go
on we have to keep going on but we just
don't have funding and you know and and
you know what but they good thinking but
always thinking
is it the radiation running amount no no
it's not a radiation right now it's it's
actually just because they're not made
very durably but but the point was that
people wanted to keep working and we had
a thing up in our office because we had
found out that the cell phone industry
had put out an RFP looking to hire
public relations firms to quote
inoculate the media against us and the
rumor was that the RFP the request for
proposals was there somewhere between 5
million and 10 million dollars so you
know we did we took a five dollar bill
and we put it in a frame and we put a
thing on a right knee officer says they
have five million we have five but we're
going to win we're not sure who won we
have time for one more short quick
question towards you can pick it pick an
easel let's have three okay okay do
cordless phones have the same effect
cordless phones are different that's
where the phones in your house the kind
of house hang on the kitchen wall the
thing that causes the radiation is the
amount of power that pushes the radio
wave signal that's where the radiation
comes from now in a cellular phone we
have to take this signal from here
several miles sometimes to a base
station that takes a big push of power
to run that signal in that direction but
the cordless phone in your house maybe
has to go between here and the bedroom
which might be 25 30 40 feet so the
distance makes it unnecessary for large
amounts of power to push the signal and
because there's not a lot of power
there's not a lot of radiation so
cordless phones are not a problem yes
what level of use are we talking about
where you start seeing the risks I think
we remember some of the studies that
have been done like on saccharin range
you'd have to eat 10 pounds of saccharin
before you start seeing the risk that
developed in some of the studies time
back at two hours a day 10 hours a day
any level developed those tools that
were non-existent we
made sure that we were able to get away
from that problem of maximum exposures
and all that so we developed tools that
measured what really happens with the
cell phone in fact as we talk about it
in the book one of the experimental
systems actually had a a tape playing
for the rats while they were being
exposed they could be listening just the
same way you'd be listening because the
noise the voice dissonance changes the
signal we found problems at the same
level of radiation that you're exposed
to every day that's what's most alarming
we're not talking about like we were
with saccharin where you have to drink
you know 40 cases of coke a day for 80
years before you see anything we're
talking about the same signals that you
receive every day when use the phone yes
I think we have it fall to her is I
probably spend 10 minutes today on the
phone for people to spend four hours
plus a day on the phone we're looking
for did you find some correlation in the
amount of tumors you found with heavy
users the difficulty is that as I
pointed out earlier to this gentleman
the amount of radiation depends more on
where you are when you make the phone
call than how long you're on the phone
so we would have to figure out a way to
chart you and chart everyone else who
uses the phone when they're making the
calls so there's no way for us to say
what amount of use in terms of minutes
or hours matters now we can say that if
you've owned a phone for five years or
owned a phone for ten years you have
relatively more chance for exposure but
that's about all we can do very impress
ice understand this those studies that
we've talked about that have been in the
papers in the past few weeks when you
take a look in the fine print and find
out how long those people use the phone
you see on the average they used it for
2 2.5 two and a half hours a month now
most of us who have phones get bills for
a thousand hours a thousand minutes 1500
minutes
something like that so another flaw in
the studies so far is these people used
phones in the early and mid-1990s for
not very much at all yes could there be
a seeing the right phone I think that
there can be a safe phone made you know
this is the most sophisticated
technology that we've ever really had
and this industry is technologically so
advanced and so proficient that there's
no reason why a safe phone can't be made
there are already for example microchips
that have been developed that cause some
type of perturbation in the signal that
may eliminate biological effects haven't
really been tested yet but those are the
kinds of things I think we can do so
there's no reason why there can't be a
safe phone the difficulty is that right
now right now consumers are not being
given the opportunity to protect
themselves that's the problem why don't
we end it there and we'll be downstairs
with the food the drink and the books
are
would like to officially thanked Jordan
good morning we're coming this evening
they can have other busy schedules to do
with this in the grand power downstairs
we do have books for sale from the GW
bookstore there will be on hand to sign
books if you care to and we have
cocktails and hors d'oeuvres